Anthony?
>> Hey, Georgia.
>> Are you okay?
>> Honestly, I have been kind of
struggling to figure out how to
write out the back end for my code.
My friend Walter told me that
I should use Ruby for it, but
I don't know Ruby and the syntax is
weird, and I don't know what I'm doing.
And.
>> Okay, let's just take a step back and
realize that you've come a long way.
You're in your strain zone right now but
that's okay.
So just tell me a little bit
about what you're doing.
>> I'm trying to build out a class for
a database so that I can store images.
>> So, you've learned about
classes in Python, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, let's just put project
compass aside for a minute,
and look at an example of a class, okay?
So, here's a class in Python for a car
object, can you explain that to me?
>> Yeah.
So, it's got a couple of attributes.
Year, make, and model, and
I see down here we have this new_car
that's a new_car object with some
of these attributes defined.
>> Okay, great.
So
let's look what this looks like in Ruby.
So, as you can see,
there are a couple of differences.
In Python, you would have to
declare self, but in Ruby,
you don't have to do that.
Also, when you create a new
instance of a variable,
you actually need the keyword.new,
but in Python you don't.
But other than that,
the logic is pretty much the same.
>> Okay, I see how they're similar.
How can I learn more about
these syntax differences?
>> So you can check out the Ruby
documentation online or you can check
out online forums because there's a huge
community to help new programmers.
In addition,
check out the Udacity forms,
that will be really helpful to you.
>> Okay.
I'll give it another shot.
Thanks Georgia.
>> You can do it Anthony,
I believe in you.
[SOUND]